si consiste en una investigación que se
realizaba durante seis meses por parte
de un portal digital aquí en el país
ecuatoriano luego de ello Ah se han
denunciado sobre una presunta estructura
de manejos corruptos por parte del
ejecutivo nacional que estaría liderado
presuntamente por Danilo Carrera y
Hernán Luque Danilo Carrera es el cuñado
el presidente de la república Guillermo
el lazo y Hernán Luque antiguo compañero
de el banco de Guayaquil ambos altos
funcionarios serían designados por parte
del presidente Guillermo lasso quienes
habrían trabajado con él durante muchos
años en el banco de Guayaquil Pero en
qué consiste se ha emitido una
información donde ya se realizan
informaciones preliminares por parte de
la fiscalía general del estado en la que
se conocería de una supuesta estructura
en el sector eléctrico en que consiste
en sobornos de funcionarios a cambio de
contratos en el sector eléctrico Cómo
afectaría bueno haría mucho más
competitivo la próxima convocatoria la
reforma constitucional y a las
elecciones regionales que estaría
dándose en Ecuador el próximo cinco de
febrero a pesar de que la mayoría de las
preguntas son ocho preguntas
relacionadas
diversos sectores de seguridad ambiente
daría la victoria al presidente
Guillermo lasso esto también debilitaría
un poco los efectos de su Victoria Pero
esto también ha reavivado también el
debate por parte de las intenciones de
destitución por parte de la asamblea
nacional quien emitiría un informe
también luego de las elecciones y
también posibles movilizaciones luego de
el cinco de febrero por parte del
sectores indígenas quienes rechazan la
consulta y se han opuesto la política de
minería por parte del ejecutivo nacional
todo esto paralelo también a las
investigaciones las fiscalías que ya ha
convocado a Danilo Carrera y algunos ex
funcionarios el presidente de la
república ha negado esto Pero ha emitido
algunas acciones conforme se van
conociendo evidencia y De igual forma
también el ex secretario de
anticorrupción Luis verdes Soto ha
emitido un informe donde habla presunta
corrupción y ha presentado su carta de
renuncia